[Music]
people don't realize when they walk
outside there's basically a grocery
stores that's such a beautiful thing
about nature a lot of my job is to walk
around in the woods and say oh what is
that in the ground pick it up and eat it
you know have this sort of curious
nature where I never satisfied with
something if we're cooking something how
can we do it better how can we make it
more interesting we have to eat as human
beings so why not make it the most
memorable experience you can my name is
James gah I am a culinary artist forager
and a founder of err little fire more
often than not we're working with
clients executing their vision so I'm
incredibly flattered that Coors Light
want to let us create a dinner that
we'll be doing later this week where we
are building a menu designed around
native species what's growing
the berkshires a good reputation for a
reason we're a little bit more north so
the growing seasons are so short so it's
really about embracing that moment in
time
ha you have to strike the thing about
James is he'd never stops Chris he holds
himself in such a high standard and when
he gets to where his dream is his own
standard goes up that's very inspiring
in a way because it pushes you to just
continue to be better just continue to
be better and continue to be better
my largest form of inspiration is going
into woods it makes me feel like this
warmth in my chest the hair stand up in
the back of my neck and I want to be
able to share that with people
that's my artistic expression to be able
to replicate that moment in time
it's used about a 17-hour day on site
it's a big experience what you have to
love it and thankfully I have that in a
team so we're on site now I'm hoping
today to get a hold of some stuff and
weren't able to get due to the massive
rain last night Wow
there's the first hen-of-the-woods I've
ever found will break off all the little
sort of petals here and just saute them
in a lot of butter a lot of salt just
fold them into these little red berries
it tastes remarkably like black pepper
put an addition
hello everyone thank you very much for
coming my goal is to really forever
change your lives today I want to have
everybody take this moment or they're
just being here present and realizing
that these aren't just weeds and grasses
but looking around and thinking of wow
that's actually like an edible grocery
store out there
I love the theater of what we do that's
something that I want to be able to give
people the theater the entertainments
exposing them to something they've never
seen really having a moment in life that
people are gonna walk away from it would
be a memory that's burned inside of them
forever as you see obviously this ice
cream involved here but this is birch
wood ice cream it's made by infusing
slices of birch wood and cream milk and
sugar overnight if you look above you
we've actually foraged pine bark and
then put it into a whole wheat flour so
these are little beignets
did you enjoy everything yeah great
thank you again for making time
sincerely it really means everything to
us that you come and be a part of this
experience it's want to open your eyes
back to nature because there's so much
that we forgot so thank you again for
all coming and I just want to take a
moment to thank Coors Light for giving
us the opportunity to tell our story
Cheers
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
you